when you were a child did you spend or  save your pocket money well I spent it  much at the time but I did save up for  something called a scale electrics set  scare lectric this was you know computer  games were only just starting and  skeletor's I think it's still around but  they were this was where you could race  cars around a track like an electric  track and it was quite expensive and i  remember i really wanted one so i asked  for money especially for my birthday to  get one and saved up some my pocket  money to get this scare that tricks that  what about you Alice what do you do with  your pocket money I save it wasn't  hoping for and nothing at the moment but  and a couple of days ago I go to go car  to my saved up Fred fantastic I think  maybe I should have got a go kart run  the scale electric sex i could never get  it to work properly because they never  the electrics never quite a win out I  think I should have done I think you  made a more sensible decision that I  made